tester tester c'est le maître mot du
gouvernement depuis plusieurs semaines
selon olivier ferrand
la france est en mesure d'effectuer sept
cent mille tests de dépistage par
semaine pourtant dans les faits la
réalité beaucoup plus compliqué les
laboratoires sont débordés les demandes
explosent depuis la réouverture des
frontières de certains pays
le gouvernement a promis 700 mille tests
par semaine mais dès le mois de mai les
syndicats de biologistes ont indiqué que
la tâche allait être très difficile voir
impossible notamment à cause du manque
de moyens c'est impossible d'arriver à
700 mille tests en une semaine
il manque des surblouse des kits de
prélèvement du personnel et puis c'est
encore un peu le bazar tous les lieux de
prélèvements n'ont pas encore été
recensés vers la plateforme censé
centraliser ces données en pratique la
france est loin des 700 mille tests
quelques 390 mille examens seulement
sont réalisés et des files d'attentes se
forment devant les laboratoires
d'analysés j'avais une ordonnance c'est
pour ça que ça a été un peu plus un peu
plus que pour les gens qui attendent
derrière
et donc voilà j'ai une ordonnance j'ai
un peu galéré à trouver un laboratoire
qui voulaient bien me prendre rapidement
donc j'ai appelé à peu près cinq
laboratoires j'ai pris la queue
mais je sais pas si je peux passer avant
parce que j'ai changé leur donne ans il
est prévu que je parte en vacances à la
fin de la semaine je vais rejoindre une
personne âgée et que je voudrais être
sûr de partir avec le microbe entre les
compagnies aériennes qui exige des tests
prouvant que les passagers ne sont pas
affectés les voyageurs pressés ou les
patients malades
les places sont chères et prendre un
rendez vous en ligne ou dans les
laboratoires devient un parcours du
combattant
près de 1,3 million de personnes vivent
dans 30 communes d'ile-de-france vont
ainsi recevoir des bons de l'assurance
maladie leur proposant d'aller faire un
test virologique dans n'importe quel
laboratoire public ou privé même s'ils
n'ont pas de symptômes olivier véran
estime que près d'un véhicule trois
millions de personnes seront testés plus
d'une trentaine de communes en ile de
france sont concernés
sur ces communes 8 se trouve en seine
saint denis et 8 dans le val d'oise
ces deux départements figurent parmi les
plus touchés par l'épidémie de
coronavirus l'objectif détecter les
foyers de contamination dormant et
prévenir une deuxième vague épidémique
alors que les laboratoires sont débordés
olivier ferrand a demandé d'augmenter
leur mobilisation pour assurer un nombre
suffisant de tests de dépistage pendant
la période estivale
d'après le président du conseil
scientifique jean françois delfraissy
une deuxième vague de kobe de 19 à
l'automne est le scénario le plus
probable même s'il n'exclut pas une
disparition du virus